All right, everybody, so here is example number one on how I would combine the daily bias technique with the air 50 strategies
So over here you can see that this was the daily candle and we closed above this candle here
so now our draw on
Liquid is gonna be this daily high so now if I drop down to let's say the five minute
That's when we want to trade the air 50 strategy. So this is the daily high
This is initially going to be going to be our draw on liquidity
Right, you can clearly see it was not breached. So as long as it's not breached
Right, we have the draw on liquidity intact. So now
What are the rules of the air 50 training strategy if you are new watcher of the strategy I?
Use this indicator
FXN Asian
session range by Rob Minty
The Asian session starts from 20 New York time till 2m New York time. I
Once the Asian session is over at 2 I mark out the Asian session high and
the Asian session low
now
When our bias is bullish in this scenario, it is I want the offer to him
I want the price to break above the Asian session high and
Close above it once it closes above it. What I'm doing is I'm using my Fibonacci from the Asian low to Asian high
Cool
Asian low
to Asian high
Now my entry is going to be from the 0.5 level or the 50% of the Asian range hence the AR 50 Asian range 50
Now our bias is bullish. So I'm going to with confidence
I'm going to take a long position here put much drop right above this low and
I'm going to go for the draw on liquidity, which is the issue the daily high
So if I play this through we get a beautiful entry and since our bias is bullish
You will see that the take profit level was hit
and
To make it up like that. You should have gotten one to two restore what I
Think this is basically the best model that you can use
It's really really good guys. All right. I think it's I think it's my favorite model at the moment
But yeah guys, let's move on to another example